un commando de tueurs assassine pierre
goldman qui avait été impliqué dans la
sphère du meurtre de la pharmacienne du
boulevard richard lenoir
en italie la terre continue à trembler
dans la région de pérouse
après les quatre fortes secousses de la
nuit dernière bonsoir le racisme le
fascisme le terrorisme qui règle ses
comptes mais qu'elle compte 7 à première
vue tout cela qu'il ya dans l'assassinât
de pierre goldman
ce juif polonais né en france comme il
s'est intitulé lui même dans le titre de
l'un de ses livres
ce militant gauchiste qui a là à
l'extrémité de son attitude
intellectuelle en commettant des hold-up
qu il reconnu mais surtout pour le grand
public ce jeune homme condamné dans un
premier procès pour l'assassinât d'une
pharmacienne et de sa préparatrice
boulevard richard lenoir à paris en 69
et a quitté ensuite après que ce
jugement était cassée pour vice de forme
par la cour d'assises d'amiens en mai 76
la cour d'assises l'innocentent à pour
ce double meurtre mais le condamna
néanmoins à 12 ans de réclusion pour
trois autres agressions à main armée
qu'il avait reconnu en prison pierre
goldman écrit des livres d'une rare
franchise
puis il a libéré sous conditions il vit
de sa plume
il collabore à des journaux qui pensent
plus ou moins comme lui on le connaît et
on l'estiment dans le quartier où il
habite place de l'abbé enoch dans le
13ème arrondissement de paris et c'est
là aujourd'hui à 12h30 qu'il a été
abattu par trois hommes et avant même
que la police est identifié la victime
c'est à dire une demi-heure après
l'assassinât l'agencé france presse
recevez un message téléphoné d'un groupe
qui s'intitulait honneur de la police
un message qui disait pierre goldman a
payé ses crimes
la justice du pouvoir ayant montré une
nouvelle fois ses faiblesses et son
laxisme
nous avons fait ce que notre devoir nous
commandaient précédemment en mai dernier
ce groupe s'était manifestée en faisant
sauter la voiture d'un militant du
service d'ordre au cgt mais vous allez
le voir dans un instant l'avocat de
pierre goldman pense que cet attentat
n'a rien à voir ni de près ni de loin
avec un acte
policiers alain rodier enquêter sur cet
attentat et éric gilbert va vous
rappeler la personnalité de pierre
goldman et venait régulièrement ici non
pas régulièrement
enfin je pense qu'il habitait dans la
vérité ne parlait jamais de rien jamais
il n'avait jamais c'est sur cette petite
place calme devant le café où il était
connu que pierre goldman a été assassiné
il passait ici fréquemment longeant le
centre de la croix rouge pour rejoindre
son domicile tout proche mais
aujourd'hui à 12h30 un commando de
tueurs étaient au rendez vous moi je
veux trois gars qui ont mené par la wii
et n'avait de tous ordres qui sont
restés là il croyait mille et mille
devant les avait déjà tiré un coup de
feu et l'est les deux et qu'ils avaient
des pantalons noirs ils sont restés là
le troisième il est nu devant le mec qui
l'attiré et là sur la poitrine
il ya eu combien de coups de feu
exactement 3 qu'est ce qui s'est passé
après après les deux mais qu'ils ont les
3000 le mec était devant il a retrouvé
ses collègues ils sont certainement
partie par là parce qu'elle paye sortir
le côté il ya une sortie de la cote et
ayant une voiture rouge qui les
attendait hier huit îles matricule et 94
mail mais qu'il avait toujours le
revolver dans sa main paris 16 décembre
1969 un jeune homme brun armé d'un p 38
vient de tuer deux femmes dans une
pharmacie du boulevard richard lenoir
la propriétaire du magasin et sa
préparatrice un policier alerté qui
tentent d'intercepter le gangster est
blessé à son tour d'une balle dans le
ventre
quinze jours plus tard à la suite d'une
dénonciation pierre goldman est arrêté
il a 25 ans fils de résistants juifs
polonais très marquée par ses origines
et révolté par l'antisémitisme
il est tombé dans la délinquance après
un passage dans les groupes
révolutionnaires d'amérique du sud
à première vue tout l'accablent dans la
sphère du boulevard richard lenoir les
témoins l'ont reconnu et s'il nie les
faits pierre goldman admet s'être trouvé
dans le quartier pour commettre une
autre agression
à laquelle au dernier moment ils
auraient renoncé de plus il a déjà
attaqué une pharmacie aussi en 1974
devant les assises de la scène goldman
est condamné à la prison à vie
mais l'accusé du boulevard richard
lenoir continue de crier son innocence
deux nouveaux avocats et peluches le
dossier qui paraît moins solide
les témoins ont varié et malgré tout les
présomptions apparente
il n'y a aucune preuve matérielle
goldman écrit un livre c'est un livre
confession il y parle de sa solitude de
sa révolte
un mouvement d'opinion se dessine en sa
faveur et 50 personnalités dont pierre
mendès-france joseph kessel simone
signoret soutiennent pierre goldman
lorsqu'ils demandent la révision de son
procès et finalement en 1976
les jurés damien acquittent pire goldman
du double meurtre des pharmaciennes du
boulevard richard lenoir
alors bien sûr il n'avait pas être d un
saint il avait lui-même assumer ses
responsabilités à l'égard des vagues de
déviance qu'il avait pu réellement
commettre mais il était devenu quelqu'un
d'inclassable certes mais restait un
militant et un militant extrêmement
généreux et c'est pourquoi sa mort n'est
pas pour moi le fait d'un groupe de
policiers car je reste persuadé que la
police dans son ensemble n'est pas mêlé
à cet assassinat mais l'assassinât d'un
petit groupe fasciste s'en prenant à
quelqu'un qui certes était l'adversaire
du fascisme alors pour achever de situer
d'essayer de situer la personnalité de
pierre goldman qu'on qualifie trop
hâtivement de juifs marginal révolté je
voudrais vous citer un passage de son
livre souvenirs obscurs d'un juif
polonais né en france il dit ses
sentiments après que le tribunal de la
somme les innocenter de l'assassinât de
deux pharmaciennes ce procès avait été
précédé d'une grande campagne en sa
faveur on viens de vous le dire
alors voici ce qu'écrivait pierre
goldman il y eut après le verdict la
campagne de presse les signatures de
personnalités tout ce nouveau tumulte
qui m'arrache et à l'intimité de ma
solitude mais mouvait mais également
blessé profondément ma passion du
silence et de l'ombre il eu les
centaines de lettres que
je reçus il y eut la solidarité des
juifs juifs communistes et juif
conservateur juif sioniste anti sioniste
et non sionistes tous dans ce procès
avait senti qu'ils étaient juifs que j
avais été totalement juifs pour moi pour
les juifs pour les autres cette
solidarité purement juive me bouleversa
alors l'actualité est ainsi faite c'est
ainsi que le racisme nous sautent à la
gorge
au moment où nous croyons naïvement que
notre intelligence est en train de le
tuer ce racisme c'est vrai que plus on
n'en parlait plus il est là bien présent
hélas demain monsieur giscard d'estaing
recevra le grand rabbin kaplan pour la
nouvelle année israélite et il est très
vraisemblable que la question du racisme
anti-juif sera évoquée